Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 275 der Sendung wo wir wir der Chaos Computer Club Berlin im weitesten Sinne sich einmal im Monat damit beschäftigen aus einer sagen wir Nord Perspektive aussieht
auf die digitale Welt zugucken und Dinge zu erklären manchmal auch zu zerkleinern das kommt ganz darauf an um welches Thema es geht wir.
Enden regelmäßig dabei.
Das wird zwar extrem haben entweder alles anzünden oder die Welt besser machen manchmal sogar beides ich bin sehr gespannt wo wir heute landen werden mein Name ist Markus Richter ich versuche durch diese Sendung zu führen und wir sprechen heute über Barrierefreiheit.
Nicht für die ganze Welt sondern erstmal nur für den digitalen Teil wie es beim Chaosradio zu häufig ist
vielleicht gehen wir auch noch wahnsinn das müssen wir aber sehen wir sprechen also darüber wie diese Welt die für sage ich mal die engere zielgruppe dieser Sendung ganz natürlich ist vielleicht doch
gar nicht so niedrigschwellig unzugänglich ist wie man das manchmal glaubt woran das liegt was man dagegen machen kann.
Und wie das vielleicht alles besser wird bespreche ich heute mit.
Niklas Schmidt = sensibilisierungs Workshops uns engagiert bei EBV hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo Markus schön dass das hier stattfindet.
Ich bin sehr gespannt dr Irmhild Rogalla sie ist fachliche Leitung des Instituts für digitale Teilhabe der Hochschule Bremen und dort auch Leiterin des Instituts für praktische Interdisziplinarität.
Hallo und guten Tag.
Hallo Markus ich freue mich dass ich dabei sein kann herzlich willkommen und dann haben wir noch Dennis morhardt erst Webentwickler und unter anderem spezialisiert auf die technische Seite von digitaler Barrierefreiheit hallo guten Tag.
Hallo Markus so jetzt ist das Thema ein.
Sensibles und gleichzeitig unterrepräsentiert des und gleichzeitig eins wo man sich als Mensch der sich nicht damit beschäftigt viel immer wenn man darauf.
Gedrängt wird oder stößt denkt da müsste ich mich eigentlich viel mehr damit beschäftigen und aus diesem sozusagen fast ein kleines bisschen Schuldbewusstsein.
Resultiert dann immer auch so eine große Unsicherheit wie damit überhaupt umzugehen ist und deswegen fangen wir
aber nicht nur deswegen weil es manchmal im Chaosradio eigentlich immer ganz von vorne an und fragen erstmal Barrierefreiheit
kann man das überhaupt definieren und ich würde die Frage aber das hätte ich nicht nach der Definition stellen sondern nicht fragen was ist Barrierefreiheit weil
instinktiv ist das glaube ich klar dass es bedeutet dass idealerweise jeder einen gleichen Zugang hat unabhängig von seinen Fähigkeiten.
Deswegen würde ich praktisch fragen ist Barrierefreiheit ein realisierbares Ziel.
Oder ein erstrebenswertes aber letztlich nicht erreichbares ideal bemüht was magst du anfangen.
Na ja also ich sag mal ich bin schon der Meinung bei ihre Freiheit ist möglich und auch anzustreben also auch wirklich bei ihre Freiheit nicht nur bei ihrer Armut
ich mache mal seit Jahrzehnten wird uns bei der Digitalisierung erzählt dass die alles besser macht.
Unglaublich flexibel ist und ich waren wir erleben da kommen wir ja bestimmt noch
auch eigentlich ein immer immer mehr angehen an vielen Stellen also wir jetzt im Sänger von all den Menschen.
Soll man irgendeine spezielle Anforderung haben und es sind ja nicht wenig und ich finde schon das an der Stelle Digitalisierung mal zeigen könnte dass Sie auch wirklich flexibel ist und zum ab
von Barrieren beitragen kann und Koch tatsächlich ich glaube da auch tatsächlich dass es technisch möglich ist und muss allerdings was dafür tun.
Gedicht von alleine das habe ich befürchtet.
Jetzt hast du aber so danke schon einen schönen Unterschied gemacht nämlich zwischen Barrierefreiheit und Barriere Armut kannst du das mal erklären.
Naja ich sag mal so bei jeder Freiheit heißt tatsächlich wenn wir jetzt mal kurz auf sowas wie eine Definition gehen dass wirklich jeder mit jeder Beeinträchtigung,
Beeinträchtigung steht jetzt hier in diesem Falle tatsächlich für verschiedene Arten von Behinderungen teilhaben kann und zwar in im Jahr.
Wirklich komplett teilhaben kann und das ist ein extrem hoher Anspruch schon an rein wenn man an
Menschen mit W Einschränkungen oder gar Blindheit entdecken
weil diese diese Einschränkung so unterschiedlich sind und dementsprechend ist auch das ganz unterschiedlich was die jeweiligen Menschen brauchen.
Ein jeder frei wenn das wirklich der Anspruch ist jeder kann gleichermaßen teilhaben würde dann bedeuten all diese verschiedenen Einschränkungen zu berücksichtigt
und eben dafür zu sorgen dass es für all diese bei ihre frei ist und das ist
unglaublich aufwendig einfach deswegen spricht man ganz oft von weil ihre Armut weil man eben den einstecken und schwanger nicht ganz erfüllt sondern nur auf der mittleren
rufe oder weil ein eben Zucker bewusst ist dass man bestimmte Menschen.
Meistens auf solche wie mich steht nicht hören können ausschließt weil das zu viel kostet das für sie bei ihre frei zu machen.
Niklas wie würdest du das Problem oder die Definition oder diese Frage einschätzen.
Tja ich glaube ich habe da diese oft gar keine fixe Antwort zu sondern nur so ein paar größere Gedanken.
Am
Ich bin im Verlauf der die haben 1 Engagement sind und der Wolf gesichtet ich mache auf den Begriff Zumutung snorm gestoßen und für mich hat der relativ viel da erklärt ich da hat den ursprünglich glauben ist gerade noch so eine schöne
zum Magazin das hieß Mondkalb ist auch so eine so ein so ein Begriff der früher für Behinderungen und so irgendwie im Urlaub war.
Zeitschrift das Magazin für das organisierte Gebrechen das erzähle ich auch nur weil es so lustig ist und die Zumutung ist Norman ist sozusagen der Gedanke.
Wenn wir uns einen ein Bordstein anschauen dann hat die an die meisten Leute da kein Problem da irgendwie hoch und runter zu hüpfen.
Kinder an der Spaß beim keine Ahnung wenn man sich überlegt überlegen diesem Deutschland machen behyar weil irgendwer das für eine schlaue Idee hält und packen den auf 20 cm dann ist es für die kleinen Kids irgendwie schon schwierig oder für jemanden der am Rollator dabei hat
Darwins kann abgesenkt Bordstein gibt's vielleicht auch einen Kinderwagen und dieses Experiment können wir könnte weiterspinnen über 50 cm 80 cm in Meter 1 Meter 20
und dann merkt man auch sie das ist irgendwie so eine flexible Skala auf der wir uns befinden.
Also es gibt so ein Moment wo irgendwie die meisten Häuser Gerhard hier ist völlig bescheuert was soll ich mit dem Bordstein irgendwie dann wieder 20 hoch ist.
Und darüber finde ich diesen Deal diese Frage über Barrierefreiheit oder bei ihrer Armut für mich immer so ein bisschen
Asbacher weil es geht auch immer um Aufwand das geht immer darum wie viel Energie kann ich oder will ich aufwenden um an irgendwas teil zu haben oder teilzunehmen.
Und es geht auch immer darum auf so einer gesellschaftlichen Ebene zuschauen na ja wie viele Leute fallen in gerade hinten runter dann also das ist ja nicht was offiziell verhandelt wird aber ich glaube da gibt es so ein intuitives Gefühl für
und ich glaube auch dass.
Im Bereich Barrierefreiheit oder bei ihrer Armut der spannende begriffliche. Ist ja Freiheit ist ja eigentlich eine absolut.
Dann und Armut kann ich auf so einer Skala und wir dann auch irgendwie angucken und ich glaube das ist für das System in dem wir leben.
Sinnvoll oder damdam87.
Mit einer Armut Idee dann zu kommen und zu seinen Hasen Ärschen schon relativ nah dran und das Ideal werden in die erreichen und so und ich glaube das auch total wichtig wie immer das gesagt hat immer wieder starken Begriff von Freiheit.
Wieder mit in den Diskurs zu geben und zu sagen sie nee es geht nicht darum irgendwie.
Nach 70 oder 80% des angenommenen Weg ist irgendwie aufzuhören.
Das hört sich für müssen für mich vermissen tatsächlicher was der Karsten Futterkorb selber sozusagen politischen Diskussion oft macht an nämlich immer die Maximalforderung stellen.
Also immer sagen es geht darum die Welt zum bestmöglichen Platz zu machen und ja auf dem Weg dahin muss man irgendwie Kompromisse eingehen das Gefecht blöd für Diskussionen aber man darf das nie aus den Augen verlieren.
Das sehe ich auch so was sind ja gerade wenn wir über Beihilfe bei jedem reden oder ihn das gegenteilige eben Zugänglichkeit wäre immer Menschen die wir ausschließen.
Und zwar teilweise komplett und digitaler die Welt wird.
Von unserem er Sachen schließen dir solche Menschen aus.
Ja und deswegen finde ich schon das Ziel muss wirklich bei jeder Freiheit.
Ich finde das Bild von dem Bordstein das hätte ich auch ganz hilfreich für mich weil trotz.
Trotz Beschäftigung mit dem Thema sozusagen habe ich immer Schwierigkeiten gehabt weil es
egal ob man ob ich das will oder nicht in meinem Kopf immer sozusagen doch ein bisschen ins ins ins Lager denken gegen mir sozusagen also wir und die
und dann sind die vielleicht drin aber gibt's immer noch die anderen und wenn man sich aber diesen sozusagen wie in dem Schieberegler veränderbaren Bordstein vorstellt der halben auch nicht nur beliebig tief sein kann und möglichst viele Leute
den den Übergang zu ermöglichen sondern auch fürs Gedankenexperiment beliebig hoch werden kann dann merke ich aufeinmal selber das
das für dich keine Barriere ist ist nur eine Frage dessen dass der Bordstein zufälligerweise nicht größer als 1,50 m ist und das merke ich hilft mir gerade im Kopf sehr dann zu verstehen dass es eben nicht eine Frage ist von
barrierefrei Beere Abendessen Zusatzaufwand soll es geht eigentlich immer um Zugänglichkeit als Zugänglichkeit ist endlich fast schon das schönere Wort.
Jetzt ist es aber so.
Dass das wohl nicht ob ich wollte kastenweg nicht mehr gerne noch Dennis da Dennis sozusagen der das als job macht Dinge im Netz.
Barrierefreier zu machen.
Jetzt will ich noch nicht auf die einzelnen Beispielen gehen weil das jetzt dass ich der nächste Punkte die mich gleich kommen will aber wenn wir über hier über Definition reden und du bist das Sagen Techniker.
Gibt es.
Nenne technische Definition ein ISO-Standard ein RFC 83 98.7 Strich C für Barriere Armut oder bei Reparaturen sein kann wenn man das
alles erfüllt hat dann hätte man zumindest nach einer technischen Definition barrierefrei.
Das ist ja nicht nur ein Word Problem das so auf dem Problem des Gesetzgebers weil der oder die müssen ja auch sagen so wann wann ist es denn dann bei ihre frei einerseits aus eigener Auflage weiß ich
langer wir sind immer digitaler mehr Behörden Leistungen gehen digitale können halt wirklich niemanden ausschließen weil sonst was Inhalt
um auf finanzielle Leistungen geht deswegen gibt es die natürlich es gibt halt
von der Witze agjus hatte von dem von vom W3 Konsortium also die die einige Web Standard schon gemacht haben von denen auch HTML zu Markt bekommt die haben tatsächlich ein Standard für und es hat einfach so gut das mehr oder weniger alle Gesetzgeber der Welt gesagt haben ihr habt ihr nehmen wir also es gibt halt in USA dieses Action five Zero eight
wie beziehen sich drauf.
Wir hatten in Deutschland die BTV und dann später die BTV 20 ST Barrierefreiheit Verordnung in der Informationstechnik
so Oma das der Hit war hat man dann irgendwann die Revision 2.0 genannt wo das war diese
da20 Fahrersitz Erden und auch die bezieht sich auf die WCAG und wir haben jetzt mit der auch auf der OP von Ebene 1
eine EU-Richtlinie.
100/200 16/21 02 müsste sein aber da kann ich ohne weitere zahlreiche schönes weiß ich der EU Gesetzgeber ja nicht auf 1 irgendwas auf dem Web im Bett beziehen kann für musst du das noch in einer OP fenorm gegossen wer das ist es gibt 1 Quali copy paced der WCAG
in die EU Norm oder europäische Norm 301549 und auf die bezieht sich da das Gesetz.
Ich habe am Ende am Ende ist hat sich die WCAG und in aktuellen Version das ist die 2.1 quasi der Standard für digitale ist im Web.
Okay wollte gerade sagen na das ist nicht ganz Wand und lass uns mal bitte jetzt darüber natürlich als nächstes reden nämlich übers Web also oder sagen wir im weitesten Sinne.
Bildschirmgeräten hatte nicht nur Webseiten sondern vielleicht auch Apps also erstmal reden würde sagen nur über diese Dinge die.
Wenn ich jetzt gerade sage so richtig weil sie an dir am Computer stattfinden oder auf dem smartphone jetzt geht es ja sozusagen.
Erstmal und vordergründig auch dazu kommen wir noch um Menschen mit Behinderung und es gibt.
Es gibt natürlich eine Sache die mir aufgefallen ist die mit dem Aufkommen von tiktok tatsächlich ganz stark zugenommen hat und das ist das viele Videos.
Untertitelt werden also gerade auf tiktok machen sich die machen sich die.
Die erfolgreichen craters also die Menschen die sagen ich große Follower in Zahlen haben und auch Geld damit verdient die Mühe des selber zu machen selber zu Untertiteln es gibt auch eine automatische Untertitelung die soweit ich das auseinanderhalten kann auch leidlich gut funktioniert und.
Deswegen wäre das meine erste Frage hätte ich wie wie barrierefrei ist im Alltag das Netz
das Web wo der Bildschirm Arbeit und Geräte und Angebote für Menschen die eine Behinderung mit oder im oder am Gehör haben.
Wirklich ich bin ich das mal so pauschal das stimmt die Untertitelung die automatische Untertitelung hat sie hat
zumindest sie ist auf englisch das muss man auch sagen ist sie.
Super gut geworden gerade in der letzten Zeit also ins war in den letzten 2-3 Jahren auf Deutsch das ist die andere Sprache wo ich selbst beurteilen kann ist es in aller Regel immer noch nicht Zumutung
man ist zwar gleich zu sagen das ist doch leidlich verständlich
das ist es auch meistens nur ich sag mal wenn man drauf angewiesen ist und das womöglich stundenlang.
Dann reicht leidlich nicht
wenn ich mir jedes, jeden. Und jede Großschreibung denken muss und dann immer noch ausgleichen muss alle Schreibfehler.
Und Namen und Zahlen notorisch dich richtig erkannt werden ebenso fremdsprach also alle Arten von fremdsprachlichen aus.
Dann ist das einfach auf die Dauer sehr sehr sehr anregend.
Also das ist das eine das ist jetzt sag ich mal die Position von jemanden der wie ich gut Deutsch kann
Nachricht also mit deutscher laut und Schriftsprache aufgewachsen ist auch schreiben und lesen kann so einigermaßen zumindestens ja wenn wir jetzt aber sage ich mal die Position derjenigen einnehmen die deren Muttersprache Gebärdensprache
Ist alle die sich selber in Gebärdensprache ausdrücken und auch mache ich mal.
Nicht nur gerne möchten sondern unter Umständen auch darauf angewiesen sind dass sie input in Gebärdensprache bekommt die sind oftmals mit deutscher laut und Schriftsprache nicht
souverän wie gehen damit nicht souverän
additional ist das sogar noch viel schlimmer aber das lassen wir mal wäscht und dann habe ich nämlich ganz schnell ein Problem also ich stehe hier ja auch mit Gebärdensprachdolmetscherin unterwegs weil das auch.
Die Kommunikation viel viel besser ist als Untertitel Untertitel reichen da nicht und ich mache mal eben dem Moment kann man sehr deutlich sagen nein.
Wenn man was möchte.
Sprache egal jetzt ob hier in Deutschland oder auch in den USA ob es in den USA ein bisschen besser ist kann man von seiner Zugänglichkeit oder gar von Komfort
überhaupt nicht reden sondern man muss kämpfen für auch nur ein bisschen Zugänglichkeit.
Wie ist das denn mit der mit der anderen sozusagen wenn man jetzt an Bildschirmgeräte denkt offensichtlichen Behinderung über jemanden reden musste nämlich Blindheit oder Sehbehinderung
auch da so dann gibt's im Kleinen etwas was mir als jemand ihr damit keine Probleme hat.
Immer wieder oder so häufiger begegnen nehme ich das auf Twitter relativ massiv dass ich auch eine Frage der eigenen Timer wie man folgen sagen eingefordert wird das wenn der Bilder gepostet werden das da auch Bild
Beschreibungen dazu gepostet werden damit die Geräte die den Bildschirmtext Ablesen sorgen im auch
darstellen können hier ist ein Bild wie ist da aber der generelle Durchschnitt kann man sagen da ist das.
Web das bildschirm Leben schon auf einem guten Weg oder ist es endlich so es gibt erste Anzeichen von aber eigentlich.
Ist das ja der hohe Bordstein ich gehe davon aus dass du das die Frage meine Richtung spielt immer immer alle die gerne möchten aber das heißt auch gerne du.
Sehr sehr schön genau also wir hatten es ja eingangs nicht erwähnt ich bin ja selbst auch so mit rechnerisch 2% Sicht unterwegs
dann bist das vorstellen zu können also auf einem Bildschirm oder Schlag ein Buch auf ich sehe von dem Wort da drin ein Buchstaben ich habe ein ganz krassen tunnelblick.
Und wird schwindelig damit manchmal auch so ein bisschen in dieser ich sag mal in Anführungsstrichen Schublade
im auch noch so zwischen den Schubladen oder zwischen den Stühlen weil ich mach viel noch mit sogenanntem seeress und mach viel mit akustischer und akustische Ausgabe.
Ich kann da immer nur für mich sprechen.
Und ich habe da teilweise also gerade was das angeht keine besonders gute Stichprobe sag ich mal
also Bilder Untertitelung in anderes Thema ist was mir immer wieder auf auf auftaucht oder was wo ich gefragt werde.
Gender in Sprache mit Sternchen dann gabs irgendwie diese Geschichte Jahr macht das doch mit Doppelpunkt weil das von den Screenreadern irgendwie für für blinde und sehr eingeschränkte Menschen anders vorgelesen wird also.
Ist glaube ich auch noch mal eine andere Frage.
Insgesamt mit den Bildern mit den ich zu tun hatte das ihrem auch also das ist glaube ich auch zum einen.
Ist das eine Kunst würde ich sagen und da fehlt ein bisschen Wissen bei den Leuten die sowas ein.
Binden oder da fehlen vielleicht auch Kurse oder oder wir irgendwie so Wissensvermittlung wenn ich auf dem Wikipedia-Artikel bin.
Und weiß ich nicht mit mir Daten Bild von.
Jane Austen irgendwie so dann interessiert mich natürlich auch wie also das dieses Bild transportieren will ist das eine Fotografie ist das.
Eine Malerei eine Zeichnung was für eine Stimmung wird der Produkte produziert so
und dann das kann jetzt sein dass irgend welche alle Leute bis ihr hören und auf ner ähnlichen Perspektive da drauf tun und 1 zu 1 gar keinen Fall dass mich alles gar nicht wissen also wir sind da auch in der Problematik von.
Den Leuten das geben was sie haben wollen irgendwie und vielleicht auch auf so ich bin jetzt mal rum auf so verschiedenen komplexitäts leveln.
Zu sagen so 11 Uhr ich will hier nur so ein kurzen Überblick ich will aber genau wissen wo wo befindet die sich da irgendwie was es auf dem Bild.
Drauf dass das Foto von der Freiheitsstatue ist dann gutes Wetter oder schlechtes Wetter also wenn ich ein Bild von der Freiheitsstatue angucken da steht drauf ein Bild von der Freiheitsstatue dann ist mir halt nicht besonders viel gewonnen.
Und einen Schritt zurück also wenn wir in diesem.
Dennis hat angesprochen in diesem Bereich von Web accessibility web content accessibility guidelines guideline oder guide also WCAG unterwegs sind.
Da sind ja nein. In der ganz langen.
Hätte ich würde mich habe letztens das versucht Leuten zu erzählen so mit so einer Kette aber Kette oder stille post also wir haben Menschen die sitzen irgendwo und.
Dann produzieren diesen content.de die die Leute bei tiktok z.b. die Leute die Website von mir was auch immer unser Eis irgendwie das Interface für Geldautomaten oder so.
Die benutzen in die Software dafür dann kommt da irgendwas raus das wird irgendwo vermittelt das wird ins Werk geladen.
Land Land auf einer Maschine.
Dann komme ich an und habe einen sogenannten User-Agent mit Browser auf einem Handy oder oder in meinem Computer auch für diese User Agent Gibson Standard von der von der W3C und auch für die.
Developer Agent auf der anderen Seite Gibson Standard.
Und dann dann kommt in die meine sister of Technology meine Assistenz Technologie dazu.
Und die versucht jetzt aus diesem Browser das ist rauszuholen was ich jetzt gerade haben will und das entweder.
In Breyell Schriften. Schrift auf einer 3 Zeile umzuformulieren oder akustisch auszugeben.
Also was damit Deutschland wird deine Zeit sehr sehr sehr sehr viele Orte an denen was schief laufen kann es reicht wenn es denn.
Auf diesen ganzen Weg halt so ein paar Standards unterwegs sind und dann sind wir natürlich auch nicht verpflichten und.
Und ähnlich ist es mit dieser Bildbeschreibung also ich da Bock drauf hat dann mache ich das und wenn ich gut da drin bin dann schreibe ich das da rein.
Und wenn nicht dann schreibt er ein Bild 2 und.
Ich werde dich ganz spannend weil die die Frage was was transportiert ein denen aus Bild ist er fast schon Interpretation konnte man sagen
und nicht so sehr meine Bild beschreiben hat aber da kann man vielleicht hinterher noch bisschen aber reden ich wollte nur noch eine Sache nachfragen wenn das schon sagen wo wir hier von Standbildern im weitesten Sinne reden
dann ist es.
Also höre ich da zwischen den Zeilen auch raus über Audiodeskription ab von professionellen Fernseher und Streaming Dienst angeboten müssen wir nicht reden.
Seine brauchst du bereden nicht so weit ich das irgendwie wirklichen kann gerade genau alles was so computergestützt irgendwie da vielleicht versucht wird oder so.
Wie sieht es denn aus wenn für Menschen mit körperlicher Behinderung im weitesten Sinne also
wird Rücksicht genommen auf besondere Eingabegeräte oder das kann ich gleich auch anders fragen weil das weiß ich gar nicht ist es überhaupt kein Problem also die die meisten Interfaces sind ja ausgerichtet auf Touch oder Maus.
Unterbinde ist mir jetzt gar nicht klar sozusagen ist ist ein Touchscreen oder eine Maus etwas was ich sehr leicht auch in dem Gerät umsetzen lässt was bestimmte Dinge aufgreift oder ersetzen kann oder ist das,
sein ist es in ähnliche Lage wie.
Wie beim beim Hören und Sehen das also die Leute die Hände haben und Finger landwehrritter faces Bauch noch nicht weiter drüber nachdenken und das ein großes Problem ist.
Jeder ist es ist tatsächlich bei den interfaces etwas leichter weil
das Stecken standardisiert ist also da kann man einfach das was Niklas eben und warte dass das so kompliziert ist und verschiedene Standard ineinandergreifen die nicht unbedingt eingehalten werden.
Das ist etwas das trifft grundsätzlich auch auf die Ausgabegeräte zu mir gab noch einmal sind die Standards eindeutiger und werden auch eingehalten weil sonst würde auch nur Maus mit Tastatur oder auch ein Tablet Tablet.
Jetzt nicht funktionieren und da kann man wohl relativ gut Daten abgreifen und die daneben
das ist ja dann eine mechanische Sache dass ich sozusagen das
Umsätze in eine andere Art von Endgerät also beispielsweise für Leute die sich gar nicht mit Händen oder Füßen bewegen können in eine Push Steuerung hast du vielleicht schon mal irgendwo
gesehen sowas
gibt es ja oder auch nur Sache ich mal dicken Ball aus dem Arsch mache für jemanden der nicht so genau sich bewegen kann aber das ist mache ich mal technischen Ebene.
Etwas einfacher meiner Kenntnis nach es ist aber ein großes Thema im Games Bereich
gewesen lange Zeit also da wo spezielle Eingabegeräte braucht und die sozusagen auch in das Gerät also jetzt in an.
Gameboy oder so fest eingebaut.
Da gab's immer nur Bastellösung allerdings gibt's da auch eine große Zähne die sich da drum gekümmert und das ist in den letzten Jahren besser geworden weil die Hersteller selbst da auch was also
da ist eindeutig also sowohl die Zähne gewachsen als auch gehen die Hersteller da mehr drauf ein und es gibt tatsächlich mehr Standards in dem Bereich
wobei man halt sagen muss das auch so aus der Web-Entwicklung her ist natürlich Unterschied macht ob man nur auf einem ausprogrammiert und dann
also ignoriert was auf der Tastatur passiert also nicht jetzt meine ich muss jetzt meinen Button der ist nur klickbar also mit der Maus dann habe ich jemanden ausgeschlossen dass ein Eingabegerät über die Tastatur funktioniert oder das Tastatur Signale sind
Fernsehbild auf der Touch und das ist ja nicht und die technische Seite das heißt ob quasi mein Button quasi alle drei Eingabeformat ist unterstützt.
Tastatur Maus und Touch ist anderes habe ich auch das Design also ich den Button zu klein mache
das einerseits jemand ist wie viel Geschwindigkeit ist der mit der Maus nicht so genau ist oder wenn wir das beste Beispiel also University sein ist natürlich wir haben ja auch temporäre Einschränkungen also wenn ich jetzt ein Handschuh trage
und auf meinem smartphone rum drücke das sind kleine Buttons bisschen nervig weil ich nicht so genau treffe.
Und da fängst dann halt an zu gucken wie kann man denn so die Zielgruppe danach sich auch erweitern für sowas als wenn wenn meine Wetter-App einfach nur so klein packen's besteht dann habe ich nicht nur Leute ausgeschlossen die eine dauerhafte Einstellung haben sich quasi alle ausgeschlossen den Karl Handschuh tragen müssen weil es kalt ist
und da fängt es halt dann an das heißt das ist auch
nicht nur ein dieStandard.at wirklich am Ende der Kette swing du dich auch schon ganz am Anfang an dem Design weil ich kann natürlich auch den Button klein machen und dann schön dass du jetzt
barrierefrei ist technisch gesehen.
Aber in Wahrheit ist es immer noch nicht also ich halte mal fest und sagen was was das zeigen auf Bildschirm angeht
ist es so dass das leichter zu emulieren geht selbst wenn sich derjenige der das Interface-Design hat keine Mühe damit gibt aber es trotzdem wünschenswert ist.
Dass man das macht aus dem grünen die Dennis gerade erzählt hat jetzt gibt es ja.
Noch mehr wo wir gerade von Computerspielen sprechen da
ist der technisch sozusagen der Maske muss auch in richtige gewesen sein dass seit einiger Weile sowohl Geräte als auch verschiedene größere spiele warnen vor.
Oder.
Warnungen für Menschen die möglicherweise photosensitive Epilepsie ausgesetzt sind es immer wieder wenn es um Texte geht geht es um um leichte Sprache Sinn.
Das Dinge die auch schon eine Rolle spielen oder sind das.
Jetzt nicht Leuchtturmprojekte wenn sowas passiert ich würde ganz gerne ja mal kurz.
Darfst du davor kurz anschließend weil ich das Thema also aus dem aus dem Bereich sehen.
Auch immer auf jeden Fall in die erwähnenswert finde es gibt auch Leute die einfach mit vergrößerungssoftware arbeiten und Kontrast Veränderung geh einfach nur sie Einschränkung haben aber.
Ja also dass das ist sozusagen das Mittel der Wahl und da ist mir gerade noch eingefallen dass.
Das natürlich auch für eine Anordnung von Buttons unten unten Aussehen von von dem user interface,
damit ein wichtiger Anspruch sein kann also wenn ich irgendwie einen großen weiß ich nicht 24 Zoll Monitor habe.
Auf dem sehe ich aber eigentlich nur das was so Scheckkartenformat.
Groß ist was ich mir gerade ganz unten links im Bild anschaue.
Dann also kannst du könnt ihr euch das vorstellen ich weiß nicht was meinst du wann hat jetzt einen sehr großen Monitor.
Wo man sich in Anführungszeichen nur einen Ausschnitt eines normalen Anführungszeichen Bild ist anschaut oder meinst du einen sehr großen Monitor aber die Software ist nicht so gemacht worden dass man Dinge vergrößern kann sondern hat einfach nur nen riesigen Monitor wo etwas ganz ganz klein draufsteht.
Wie was ich meine ist du guckst dir in Interface mit Name weiß ich nicht 300% Vergrößerungen.
Dann ist ja sozusagen der Bereich den du auf deinen Monitor sehen kannst im Vergleich zu normal 100%.
Kleiner bei dir Dinge dreimal vergrößert hat wie eine Lupe eben.
Genau und wenn ich dann irgendwie aufnehmen interface oben links oben rechts in den Ecken oder auch noch unten in der Mitte irgendwelche Buttons finden muss.
Da muss ich ja muss ich sozusagen werden meinen Sicht Ausschnitt weiter verschieben okay.
Also das macht sozusagen so eine Button Interaktion auch noch mal schwieriger das wollte ich.
Ist einfach nur noch hinzufügen das hat das heißt das sagen wann hat er denn wirklich so eine Art gordischen Knoten weil einerseits dürfen die Buttons nicht so klein sein dass man sie einen normalen sich gar nicht mehr treffen kann andererseits
dürfen sie auch nicht zu groß und zu weit auseinander sein weil man sonst mit einer Vergrößerung sozusagen in Schwierigkeiten kommt.
Das wäre das da scheinen wir spannende Herausforderung verborgen zu sein naja.
Für Dennis mach du mal das ist aber die abba Erwartbarkeit glaube ich also das ist das Ding 4 wenn du aus dem eigenen Alltag ist wo erwartest du denn die Suche auf einer Webseite Gesuch button.
Meistens oben rechts
irgendwie so gelernt funktioniert einigermaßen viele halten sich daran das ist dieses Erwartbarkeit und hatte sich Anfang so ein Formular zu haben wo der der absende Button aber
was nicht oben rechts ist unten links oder irgendwo versteckt dann machst dann ist es halt schwierig so da kann der barrierefreie sein aber dann trotzdem nicht verständlich so,
ich habe gerade überlegt vielleicht gibt's viele Menschen die sich nicht mit dem Thema beschäftigen ein ganz hervorragendes Beispiel wie man sich das vorstellen kann stellt euch vor das ganze Netz wäre so programmiert wie Cookie Banner.
Also sag im Sinne der der.
Irreführung der möglichst sollst du falsch wohin klicken und so natürlich fing dieser Vergleich wie alle Vergleich aber vielleicht kann man diese beichten das auch so sagen so ein kleines Bordstein Bild
ich bin gar nicht schlecht also auf jeden Fall weil es da ja um um Intuition oder dem hund intuitives Design geht genau und ich glaube ein eine Idee die.
Na bei mir nur so im Hirn und ein bisschen rum schwimmt ist vielleicht ist ein Weg zu sagen denn ich als als User.
Wir konnten irgendwie zugänglich machen will dass ich einen Interaktion Hersteller und sage bitte stell mir den konnten auf diese Art und Weise da also es muss ja nicht ein Interface
Für alle Menschen geben also vielleicht gibt's da ja auch eine Möglichkeit zu sagen hey ich sende da irgendwie.
So genauso wie wir jetzt ja auch schon mobile Version von Website haben und irgendwie did it mein Browser kriegt das hin und checke da irgendwie bin ich jetzt mobil unterwegs oder ist das mein Desktop-PC.
Also vielleicht ist das auch eine Möglichkeit in der Richtung weiter zu denken so aber ich bin halt keinen IP schwimmen.
Die hat die definitiv gibt's die also das ist das ist glaube die meisten Nerds kein ja den Dark Mode
Ja und den der wird jetzt davon von Webseiten ja auch respektiert weil der Browser quasi der Webseite sagt ey die Nutzerin der Nutzer würde jetzt gerne die Webseite in dunkel haben und so geht es dass ich auch so Sachen wie
hier die Person möchte reduzierte Animationen haben
so oder hat einen hohen Kontakt modus angeschaltet und doch diese Informationen kann man und sollte man halt reagieren
am Ende ist halt diese schönen Prinzipien aus der WCAG sind um die Wahrnehmbarkeit Bedienbarkeit Verständlichkeit und der viert. Robustheit
das heißt man muss auch eine Webseite so programmieren dass in Zweifel wenn die Nutzerin
die Schriftgröße auf 100% gestellt hat das ist immer noch funktioniert das muss auch immer noch funktionieren die webseite das ist jetzt in der Anforderung der WCAG 2.2 z.b. wenn die Nutzerin.
Die Zeilenabstand hoch gedreht hat weil das einfach hilft und da muss man da drauf dann damit testen musst einfach quasi mal bewusst versuchen einfach die Werte wirklich hoch zu drehen zu gucken was passiert es gibt echt so so.
ZX wo sagen so ja hier ist bist du bis pensive Schriftgrößen zum Kater hat Wahrheit jahrelang dass die dass die Schriftgröße sich automatisch an die browserbreite anpassen 40 raus dieser technische Hack sicher
und bei ihrer unfrei weil hat das besorgt wenn Nutzerin ihre eigene Schriftgröße im Browser eingestellt haben also quasi vom Standard abweicht dass das komplett um die Ohren geflogen
ist aber halt einfach quasi hat sich hat erstmal paar Jahre gedauert bis dann gereift ist dieser erkenne ist unser vorrangiges aber der Schaden ist trotzdem entstanden
so und das hat da muss man halt mal gucken ob es halt wirklich am besten tretet man wirklich gegen seine eigene Webseite ordentlich bei gegen und guck was er runterfällt.
Ich habe ich habe gerade einen Verdacht.
Es passt mir ja so sagen ich mach das mit dem Chaos Raum jetzt schon ne Weile und was mir häufiger passiert ist folgendes man spricht über Dinge
und dann sagen Mensch die davon Ahnung haben eigentlich wäre es gut wenn es auch dabei wäre also Datenschutzes so ein schönes Beispiel
und dann gibt es Menschen die machen ganz viele der stillen neue Produkte und überlegen sich dann hinterher ja Moment mal jetzt musst du auch noch da drunter vielleicht können wir die noch irgendwie drauf
und mir scheint es dir genauso also wenn dir das so erzählt scheint mir dass die praktische Erfahrung auch ist Leute designen ein Interface und dann kommt hinterher jemand Datum
wie wäre es eigentlich mit so ein bisschen Zugänglichkeit und dann wenn man es dann sozusagen versucht rein zu rein zu friemeln weil ich das Wort man verwenden darf dann hat es ihr.
Zum.
Dann seid Ihr ja schwieriger oder aufwendiger dann mal hört mal also vielleicht auch dann möglicherweise das Argument dass dabei sehr aufwendig wenn wir das jetzt auch extra dazu machen müssen und.
Es gibt ja beim Datenschutz das schöne Schlagwort privacy-by-design
was eben genau sagt wenn ihr neue Daten Angebote macht überleg doch gleich von Anfang an wie die daten unfreundlich funktionieren können und nicht erst so sagen wenn Sie fertig sind
Verdacht hier.
Oder Frage an euch ist das bei der Zugänglichkeit barrierefrei barrierearm und auch exakt dasselbe Problem in grün.
Was vielleicht nicht so gutes für Menschen verachtet Stolpersteine über aber ist es sagen eine ähnlich gelagertes Problem der Missachtung.
Das dass man sagen müsste eigentlich wenn wir zu dir midi einziehen geben wollen dass alles barrierefrei ist müsste man das immer von Anfang an mit denken aber das ist was das passiert viel zu selten.
So ist es definitiv also das Stichwort heißt sieht der SS ability bei dir sein und wenn du noch eine dritte parallele haben willst und dass auf der Bereich ist es ja schon funktionieren ist security by design
daran viele schrankpapier tatsächlich haben alle drei Dinge dasselbe Problem
man muss von Anfang an dran denken wenn man von Anfang an dran denkt und wenn die Leute es auch können also dazu in der Lage sind wissen was es bedeutet.
Dann klappt das auch dann ist es auch plötzlich nicht mehr besonders aufwendig sondern irgendwann.
Da sind wir aber bei Accessibility also bei privacy-by-design sind wir da noch mich und bei Accessibility weil Design sind wir da auch noch.
Wenn ich da mal eben was erzählen darf aus meinem früheren Leben sozusagen befruchte ich Leiterin des Instituts für digitale Teilhabe geworden bin ich nämlich ganz ganz lange 2005
in der Entwicklung des europäischen Kompetenzrahmen European competence framework.
Gibt es mittlerweile auch in anderen europäischen Natel
er war ja Version 4 und der beschreibt halt verschiedene Kompetenzen von Fachkräften in der IT Branche aber eben auch darüber hinaus also sowas wie ja was bedeutet es denn Softwareentwicklung das ist so der Klasse kam wirklich zu können aber es gibt auch eine Kompetenz die heißt
der stinkt und so weiter und so fort insgesamt über 40 mit
und was soll das haben Expertinnen und Experten aus verschiedenen europäischen Ländern gemeinsam entwickelt.
Und das Problem bei dem Ding war immer.
Und ist bis heute was machen wir mit diesem Bärchen Stinger also genau Sicherheit Datenschutz und
eben und seit einiger Zeit auch Accessibility und tatsächlich haben wir jetzt in der neuesten Version die letztes Jahr Haus gekommen ist das wirklich als.
Querschnitts Aspekte auch noch mal hervorgehoben also es gibt jetzt sozusagen immer mindestens ein Kompetenz die sich wirklich explizit auf den Bereich zieht also.
Z.b. Security aber es gibt eben zusätzlich.
7 sogenannte transversus aspects darunter eben Sicherheit Accessibility und privacy wo wir sagen das muss in jeder Kompetenz
mit drin sein und immer mit berücksichtigt werden das ist jetzt erstmal nur auf Papier ist völlig klar aber das ist die Richtung.
Indie das meines Erachtens gehen muss genau um dieses Ding hinzubekommen ja da muss man von Anfang an dran denken.
Jetzt würde mich interessieren wie man das gut motivieren kann weil bei privacy-by-design das ist ja so bettelte das den Kapitalismus Problem dann bestellen wir mal
beim alles anzünden bei der alles anzünden Kategorie fällt vielleicht schwieriger privacy-by-design zu denken weil der tatsächlich denn monetäres Interesse dran besteht das eben genau die Preise sind nicht bei dir sein darf
aber bei security by design er mit weil du das gerade gesagt hast das zeichnet sich ja tatsächlich so ein bisschen ab also es gibt immer noch genug Unfug der getrieben wird aber ist halt nicht so ein bisschen ab dass ich langsam aber sicher die Erkenntnis durchsetzt wenn ich security by design mit denke ist es eben nicht nur ein zusätzlicher Kostenfaktor sondern das sorgt hat täglich dafür dass man meinen System weniger selten
um die Ohren fliegt und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage der also nicht dass das die Motivation sein sollte
aber wenn wir uns in der bösen Kartenwelt um kriegen ist es ja manchmal so dass das vielleicht doch Hilfe man sagen kann also Accessibility by design
hätte nicht nur den idealen Zustand ist er möglichst viele Menschen mit Reinhold dir sonst ausschließt weil dann können die Leute sagen das zu uns aber egal dieses das ist eine viel zu kleine Zielgruppe dir viel zu wenig Geld.
Hat das denn auch.
Andere also wenn man es Accessibility ByDesign denkt hat dass andere Effekte die sich vielleicht positiv auf digitale Angebote oder interfaces auswirken und Spiele damit z.b. auf das an was Dennis gerade gesagt hat wenn man eben dafür sorgt dass ich Dinge leicht klicken lassen
dann kann man vielleicht Smartphones auch mit dem Handschuh bedienen.
Gibt es sowas als als größere Motivationshilfe die man sozusagen den unwilligen unterschieben könntet noch mehr wo man sagen kann der Accessibility ByDesign ist gut für alle.
Ja ist es definitiv also ist
ist ja ne Menge Technologien die aus diesem ist das bewilligt überreich in den allgemeinen übergegangen sind ich würde hier aber tatsächlich
kapitalistisch etwas anders argumentieren wollen
ich sag mal Mann ist verträglich bei Accessibility an behinderte Menschen zu denken tatsächlich ist es aber so das ja.
Das viel mehr Menschen betrifft und insbesondere das ist wichtig und da will ich drauf gehen auf die ganz große und immer größere werdende Gruppe der älteren Menschen
also nicht nur bei Behinderung und
älteres weint sich stark überschneiden sondern weil man einfach mit dem Alter das merken wir die wir hier versammelt sind ja auch
man kann halt
schlechter sehen man kann schlechter hören man kann sich schlechter bewegen und so weiter und umso mehr Probleme hat man unter Umständen mit dem digitalen
also mit digitalen die weiß es eben weil die Knöpfe zu klein sind die Farben nur Grautöne haben oder sonstiges.
Stelle Schattierung und so weiter so jetzt haben wir ja bisher das so gehabt dass wir immer das Phänomen hatten ok Internet und digitales das ist mehr was für junge Männer
schon länger vorbei ist aber die.
Also wir kommen ja mehr und mehr in die Situation dass diese ganze digitale Welt wird sich von allen Menschen
Und Nord und damit erschließt man Mitesser stability by design halt auch die sehr sehr große Gruppe der Seniorinnen und Senioren oder wie sie an anderer Stelle auch heiß super Asia.
Und die grey Gamer nicht zu vergessen.
Also das wären so das gut kapitalistische Argument was ich über statistisch auch unglaublich gut also was geht Nutzerzahlen und Veränderung müssen uns das Verhältnis angeht belegen lässt
ja also ich
also da anzugreifen also einzugreifen sorry ist das wirklich versucht es auch den Leuten zu erzählen also erzählt wird er mich vor paar Jahren als das erste mal mit dem Thema auch selber in den Park rein gegangen bin dann dieses so die sind ja nicht unsere Zielgruppe.
Wieso nein so funktioniert das nicht
und das hilft die Denkweise wirklich also aus meiner gibt von Microsoft deren Designabteilung hat so eine schöne Grafik in der hat wirklich so in so einem Sondertabelle aufgezeigt ist es gibt halt Situationen Frank und temporäre und
dauerhafte der Klassiker ist was eine App die kannst du nur mit zwei Händen bedienen das ist alles jetzt doof wenn du halt nur einen Arm hast aber das ist aber auch doof für Millionen von Eltern die gerade ein Baby auf dem Arm haben.
Die können eine App auch habe ich benutzen und ist ein riesen Zielgruppe die du damit ausgeschlossen hast herzlichen Glückwunsch damit sende deine Verwertbarkeit deiner Applikationen webseite weg
so da muss man halt einfach mit rein denken und zu müssen es meiner sich nicht auf dieses Thema gestoßen bin oder ob als Entwickler ist bei seine gesetzlichen Zwang dazu gab also die Kundinnen die.
Bei meinem Arbeitgeber aufgetaucht sind die müssen das machen
widerwillig ab sie müssen es machen und so stand ich dann vor dem Denken mir hat das auch keiner so richtig beigebracht und es gibt doch das ist immer noch nicht so richtig der.
Umgang in der beruflichen Ausbildung ich hatte dass ich jetzt vor zwei Jahren mein Fachinformatiker nach Gurt also quasi wirklich die berufliche Ausbildung die und dass mein Beruf ist da kommt das noch nicht vor,
das Wasser 1020 so das ist bisschen komisch ehrlich gesagt weil das so langsam einerseits weil auf der EU Gesetzgeber irgendeiner jetzt sagt so leute ihr müsst mal bei ihre frei werden auch im im gewerblichen Bereich
aber andererseits die schießt damit einfach wirklich Millionen von Menschen aus die liebend gerne Geld und bezahlen würden für Services aber sind nicht bereit sind bei ihre frei.
Da okay.
Ich glaube das kann man auch so stehen lassen als als Argumentationshilfe für die die nur auf den Profit schauen ich würde gerne noch mal zurück wenn sozusagen zu den zu den verschiedenen Dingen weil wir mit ganz viel bei Bildschirm mal geredet und und Smartphones also.
Bildschirmgeräte ich wiederhole mich ich würde aber gerne so ein bisschen weitergehen was auch so Tanktechnik ist das eine was mir aufgefallen ist was ich ganz interessant fand ist Bankautomaten hatten lange Zeit Knöpfe.
Und diese Knöpfe hatten lange Zeit Brei Zeichenwaren also sagen ertastbar auch wenn man nicht gut gucken konnte.
Vermute ich ich kann sagen immer nur vermuten weil ich selber da keine Erfahrung habe und jetzt werden zunehmend diese Interfaces als Touchscreens angeboten das ist
technisch gesehen sozusagen an Vortritt aber für die Achse Accessibility doch aber eigentlich erwidern Rückschritt oder.
Oder wird es irgendwie aufgefangen gibt's mittlerweile haptisches Feedback an Bankomaten also mit mit Rückgriff
auf die auf die Folge zu ich glaube es war Reverse-Engineering oder so sag ich einfach auch mal es kommt drauf an vielleicht wird es dir sagen ich glaube das kommt tatsächlich sehr auf die Perspektive drauf an
wenn ich Person oder ist keine Person die die haben Schwierigkeiten damit Knöpfe zu drücken,
Sanda geht's irgendwie um Unbeweglichkeit in den Händen oder um um Schmerzen Erkrankungen und so weiter insofern.
Und und Touchscreens Antwort auch das was wir was wir mittlerweile als Smartphones da technologischen unseren Händen halten und Hosentaschen und tragen oder was auch immer
das kommt ja soweit ich da richtig informiert bin auch aus einer Idee raus da Menschen das zugänglich zu machen und dann also das schließt auch so ein bisschen anders wird an was wäre das gerade Dennis gerade gesagt hat und dann.
Müssen sich alle so yeah.
So geil hier überall drauf rum wischen und so er ist gar nicht nur gut für die Leute die da irgendwie eine motorische.
Oder taktile Einschränkungen für mich jetzt klar also bei mir geht natürlich komplett der der Rage Modus an wenn ich da wieder vor dem Geldautomaten stehe.
Es gibt das also meistens oder manchmal ich habe noch nicht gezählt ich musste vielleicht mal eine kleine Studie machen wir machen das Leben dran anekdotische Evidenz.
Ja sehr schön was mir schon untergekommen ist sind so Buchsen für Kopfhöreranschlüsse
also ich kann dann irgendwie meine Kopfhörer rauskramen dann muss ich halt nur wissen wo diese Buchse ist
dafür muss ich natürlich irgendwie im Zweifelsfall auch zu Pandemie Zeiten einmal komplett dieses ganze Ding irgendwie ab ab Fingern fantastisch und.
Dann dann funktioniert das eventuell wobei ich da ist wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin nicht ich vermeide das ich bin so ein alter vermeide ich dich hatte.
Lange ich beklage nicht ausprobiert weil ich zu waschen beim Smartphone ist es ja so wenn ich dann meine meine Sprachausgabe meine Assistenz Software dahin gelaufen habe dann verändert sich auch der input also.
Wenn ich mit dem Finger irgendwo drauf bin dann sagt er mir was das ist und wenn ich das Aktivieren bin muss ich zweimal tippen.
Dann anstatt dass ich da einfach einmal drauf hemmer und da weiß ich jetzt gerade gar nicht so genau wie das bei dem Geldautomaten.
Aber im Prinzip treu also im Prinzip zu sagen für die Idealvorstellung von meiner Wahrheit bräuchte man eigentlich beides dann bräuchte den Touchscreen.
Für die die keine Knöpfe drücken können und man bräuchte die Anpassbarkeit und das haptisches Feedback für die die nichts auf dem Screen sehen kann.
Und im Zweifelsfall vielleicht noch irgendwas
eine Person die heißt mit somit mit Eyetracking ihre Sachen steuert oder mit einem pustete mit einer fußverstauchung oder so also da bin ich dann auch gerne bereit irgendwie komplette radikale Brand.
Brand Breite genau Bandbreite wieder bei anzünden.
Genau also bis dann noch mal zu überlegen okay.
Ja wenn was passiert dann wenn wir uns noch aus richtig verrücktes überlegen und und dann aber sagen ja aber auch für diese Leute soll das doch zugänglich sein also.
Genau ich will gerne mal sagen dann kurze Science-Fiction Frage stellen und zwar ist es ist ja immer wieder sozusagen wird.
Erfolge ich am Rande des über haptisches Feedback
auf dem Display du dann das daran geforscht und gearbeitet wird ist das eine Zukunftsperspektive dass man sagt die Screens selber haben auch haptisches Feedback oder ist das noch soweit in der Zukunft dass wir da heute eigentlich gar nicht drüber reden müssen.
Weiß ich nichts zu sagen weiß weiß nicht was okay na also ich mag zwar kommen aber ich glaube der der Fälle und Nerd kennt ja die lustigen Bilder von Geldautomaten mit Windows XP.
Die sind technisch ja also die sind stabil gebaut würde man vielleicht eine freundlich formulieren
das hat sich jede Neuerung auch in riesen Compliance Ding das Ende steht ja im Zielkonflikt mit mit sowas zu Banken an zu Sicherheit und Anforderungen an so Geldautomaten haben müssen und wenn habe ich der Geldgeber gehabt das muss bei ihre frei sein.
Dann fällt das Attribut da weil dann halt andere Dinge für die Bank wichtiger sind so.
Na ich Geldautomaten müssten so bei ihre frei wie möglich sein weil das ist halt der universellen Zugang zu Geld weil kann halt nicht sagen so na ja aber die Person Kira zum Schalter gehen auf der Schalter hat was offen von 9 Uhr bis 12 Uhr an und geraden Wochentagen
das ist halt wie die Deutsche Bahn die einmal sagt so ja klar wenn du verheißen willst ja auch meld deine Reise bitte 48 Stunden vorher an oder nimm den Seiteneingang der Vordereingang ist ja für normale Leute und dann fängt halt an das ist halt alles irgendwie.
Also ausschließen dass ich das nicht möchte also ist man müsste eigentlich sagen so radikal müssen frei sein oder gar nicht so dann ist halt dann so.
Also ich halte mal sagen aber die die technische Antwort ist und sagen falls du was kommt kommt es zuerst auf Geräten die profitorientiert verkauft werden und dann erst sehr sehr sehr viel später
Bankautomaten die Windows XP
ich frage mich ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile könnte ich mir vorstellen höherer innen die Bahn noch nicht mal geboren als Windows XP die die Standard der Standard Betriebssystem auf Windows Computer an war.
Aber wirklich das alte dazugehört so alt ist dass das ist sozusagen wirklich Zeug das kann man letztlich das hätte schon einen Platz verdient im technologischen Museum das wird aber heutzutage noch benutzt um Bankautomat zu betreiben.
No shit noch mal Irmisch
aber vielleicht darf ich daran anknüpfen ja eigentlich ist er Bargeld wird merken verlangt also von daher wäre es gleich viel sinnvoller wenn wir uns Gedanken darüber machen wie es eigentlich mit der Barrierefreiheit irgendwelchen oder gar das bezahlen mit Smartphone
oder der dann irgendwann kommenden weiß nicht was Technologie bestellt ist als über ja.
Windows XP Bankautomaten wobei hierbei Design und vielleicht sogar in der Technik Vorausschau
wobei hier ist dein schein interessanten Zielkonflikt auf uns zukommen sehe weil er Kartenzahlung.
Schon nicht so richtig doll privacy-by-design ist weil dann halt einfach noch eine dritte meistens auch eine vierte Partei weiß
was ist gerade wo wann an welchem Ort gekauft habe wenn man das noch ins Handy verlagern weißen das potentiell noch zwei bis drei Leute mehr.
Und das ist das ist auch ein Spannungsfeld in dem man sich bewegt oder.
Ich glaube dass der tschuldigung ich glaube das sind total wichtiger. Also diese.
3 bei Designprinzipien die wir da jetzt irgendwie so ein bisschen aufgeschlüsselt oder oder es angeschaut haben zu gucken dass die irgendwie harmonieren sollen ne also das schöne am guten Bargeld ist halt das ist echt verdammt anonym.
Ist ist das generell so was es gibt ja so Dinge da sagt man manchmal so salopp das in Luxusprobleme
und gerade Datenschutz ist sozusagen schönes Beispiel also WhatsApp immer noch ein Lieblings Beispiel ist hat unfassbar einfach WhatsApp zu benutzen wenn dann der Datenschutz
egal ist und der kann halt vielen Menschen auch egal sein sage mal jetzt hier sozusagen auf der nördlichen Halbkugel in der Demokratie.
Und.
Ist das ist das eigentlich sozusagen sogar will dieses Thema reden dass man sich manchmal heute schon Accessibility erkaufen muss indem man die beiden anderen ByDesign sozusagen vernachlässigt.
Ich glaube schon also kaufen im Sinne von na ja irgendwie muss ich da eine in der Art von Transaktionen gehen ne also wie oft ich irgendwie ich meine ich habe mit dem ganzen Thema Seheinschränkungen.
Seid seit über 20 Jahren irgendwie zu tun also ich gehöre eben da auch zu einer Gruppe die spät.
Aber nicht sehr spät damit zu tun hatten also man unterscheidet sonstige frühkindlich und dann in die altersbedingt und bei mir ich hänge einmal wieder dazwischen und sie oft Leute zu mir gekommen sind in diesem über 20 Jahren gesagt und ja den Kaffee noch einfach ein iPhone.
Das funktioniert doch super da hast du doch die komplette Accessibility und nicht nur dass man dafür ja überall so
Andy bei ihre finanzielle Machbarkeit irgendwie Gerät und an die Barriere.
Niklas Schmidt großer Datenschutz fanatica.
Problematik suche dann also dann stehe ich da und denk so na ja okay geil ich kann jetzt irgendwie.
Meine Ansprüche oder oder irgendwie meine Bedürfnisse da über Bord werfen um in den Pool nutzen zu können und dass Funktion also ja das funktioniert.
Ich sag mal leider extrem gut was da was da aus dem Haus kommt also.
Ja es klappt also und ähnlich ist es ja auch also selbst wenn ich in Android Smartphone
benutze und mich nicht darum kümmern da irgendwas anderes eine Custom-Rom drauf zu laden und dann muss ich aber dann irgendwo brauche ich noch meine ist assistant technology und so aber die kommt dann auch wieder vom großen geh und dann.
Muss man irgendwie rausfinden ok Wer funkt da irgendwie wie oft wird dann nach Hause telefoniert und so also das ist extrem aufwendig.
Pimmel.
Ja es ich kann da sogar noch ein paar Horoskop beigetragen also dafür bitte hier die Fernsteuerung.
Ein wunderbares Thema.
In die allermeisten herrschte also daran beteiligt sind mindestens derjenige oder diejenige die die Hörgeräte trägt der Hörgeräteakustiker oder Akustiker drin und der Hersteller
die allermeisten Hersteller von Hörgeräten machen es genauso wie die aller meisten Autohersteller sie wollen alle Daten haben
nicht dafür geben sie verraten einen nicht mal welche Daten sie alle erheben also.
Ja ja und ich warte mal bei digitalen Hörgeräten dann könnt ihr euch ja problemlos vorstellen mach Bahndaten anfällt also nicht dass man den Inhalt aufnehmen kann ja wir wissen ja wie aussagekräftig allein.
Also Sonnentanz typisches Beispiel kommt noch dazu dieselbe Erfahrung die Niklas gerade auch schon schilderte wenn man drüber seine haben will muss man auch Google.
Auf meinem Handy installieren also da habe ich vielleicht gekämpft aber es geht nicht also ohne Google Dienste
geht es nicht das ist die eine Geschichte ich möchte aber noch mal eine ganz andersartige
Geschichte auch dazu beitragen über die ich mich auch ziemlich aufrege und zwar erstmal unabhängig von der
digitale Welt und schwarz.
War und bin ich ja viel auf Handschaltung unterwegs irgendwie in den Kontext den ich eben schon sagte er Stellung europäischer Framework überhaupt Entwicklung frankenhofen und so weiter
und ich war auf einer und sag mal die Leute mit der Zeit auch gelernt dass ich mit Gebärdensprachdolmetscherin unterwegs bin.
Typischerweise bin ich in dem Kontext und auch sonst weit und breit die einzige die mit Gebärdensprachdolmetscherin unterwegs
auf der Veranstaltung hast dann so die verteilte sich auf mehrere Räume also
sozusagen Workshops und die zeitliche Abstimmung war nicht besonders und wir waren in unserem Raum fertig und indem wollten den haben den Raum gewechselt
meine Dolmetscherin gehen vor nach vorne weil sich klassischerweise eben auf oder neben der Mühle
sitzen und eine ganze Reihe von Menschen die da sitzen dreht sich um um mich zu begrüßen.
Alle wussten wenn die Dolmetscherin kommen dann kommt auch Frau Rogalla.
So das war in dem Fall mitbekommen die ich kenne und die mich kannten aber ich sag mal in der digitalen Welt.
Dafür dass man überhaupt teilhaben darf also dafür dass es überhaupt Dolmetscherin geht immer offenbaren zu müssen dass man halt nichts hören kann.
Habe mit Palmen sticht aber auch gar nichts zu tun
und das geht ganz vielen anderen Menschen genauso also das habe ich jetzt nicht spezifisch aufhören oder so bezogen er muss immer damit man überhaupt teilhaben darf.
Sozusagen eine der der intimsten Informationen die es überhaupt gehen schon mal öffentlich machen und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt.
Wer daneben das ist quasi sagen ein sich outen müssen.
Ich möchte das als hässlich.
Doch gerne noch mal was über ein Thema über dass wir auch schon häufiger geht haben das noch mal anschneiden was auch belächelt wird oder sagen für für Stuten und Augenrollen sorgt nämlich künstliche Intelligenz das,
das kam ja vorhin schon mal so da so ein bisschen auf bei der Untertitelung da wird es ja eben durch maschinelles Lernen gemacht oder andersrum Untertitelung Algorithmen funktionieren oft
durch maschinelles Lernen und das ist das was wir landläufig sozusagen unter künstliche Intelligenz hören wenn in den Medien darüber berichtet wird ist die Hoffnung
da das ist sage durch die Technologisierung von übersetzungs interfaces in welcher Richtung auch immer.
Dieses also a das Problem der Zugänglichkeit generell verbessert weil es halt sozusagen den Babelfish im Ohr gibt oder man.
Eine automatisierte textu irgendwas Übersetzung auf einem Display vielleicht hat dass das besser wird und dass das kommt dass man sich deswegen
dass ich deswegen vielleicht Anbieter auch ausruhen und sagen das wird irgendwann von Technologie erschlagen das müssen wir nicht von Hand machen und dass das aber auch eine Hoffnung ist die man hat also ist spielt das eine Rolle,
oder ist das wie in anderen Fachgebieten auch es gibt diese Schlagwort KI wird alle unsere Probleme lösen und die Leute die Ahnung von Accessibility haben sagen so.
Ja wahrscheinlich mit der blockchain dann erst mit der blockchain immer in genau weil ich drauf habe na ja also soweit ich weiß ist das Problem oder ein Problem in dem Bereich
die Datenlage also ich dreht jetzt gar nicht unbedingt über so Sachen die.
Schlechte Datensätze dirty data oder so sondern wenn wir uns ich weiß nicht wie viele Sprachen es auf dieser Welt gibt.
K200 oder so ist Fischen im Trüben aber.
Ich habe mich von der Weile mit einem mit einem Kollegen unterhalten der Linguistik Bereich im Verlagswesen arbeitet und der meint das Problem ist.
Dies gibt eine Handvoll Sprachen wo so
Daten überhaupt erhoben werden können weil die vier gesprochen werden weil es viele Aufzeichnung gibt viele Ressourcen die man da irgendwie konsultieren kann das hört aber
also nach deutsch englisch spanisch italienisch russisch war glaube ich auch noch dabei also.
Genau Chinesisch auch weil es ihm also kommst Du darauf an wie viele Leute sprechen das viactiv wird das benutzt welche welche Quellenlage gibt es und dann ist irgendwann ganz schnell Schluss.
Es ist ja noch dass das Ding ist ja bei den bei den Modellen Zettel Facebook benutzt um alternative Texte für Bilder zu generieren ja das ja das spuckt halt.
Sachen raus ob sie können Alter
nicht hilfreich sein weil das Ding also ja das kann.Ich auch immer noch besser werden wenn wir natürlich auch wieder mit neuen Daten füttern aber es hat die Frage kriegt man dann dieses Modell
dann auf jedes Handy auf jedes Gerät drauf wenn das dann so riesig wenn es die ganze Welt im Zweifel erklären muss soll das ist abgefuckt ist ja Augen ersetzen die ja und das ganze Wissen dass wir über das im Leben er sammelt haben um die Welt zu interpretiert das muss diese dieses KI ist ein Model am fertigmachen
unter min haben wir doch Pflicht und zentralisierten Dienst wo wir alle unsere Bilder hoch schicken und dann sieht gibt es das wieder zurück dann sind wir wieder bei Paris sieht alles bisschen doof so.
Also das heißt,
für mich sozusagen der ab und zu dieser Sendung Sitz und diese Fragen stellt wird die Zukunft echt nicht alle Probleme lösen könnte man zusammenfassen es ist hier so wie in anderen Bereichen auch vielleicht ja
aber das ist also unklar und B noch insoweit der Zukunft dass wir uns heute nicht drauf verlassen wollen ist das sozusagen vielleicht eine grobe Zusammenfassung die man da treffen könnte.
Ja aber im Bereich ist das ability tatsächlich noch zu verbinden mit einer deutlichen Warnung nämlich das was du vorhin gesagt hast es gibt dann zu viele Leute die glauben auch das funktioniert ja automatisch und wir müssen nichts anderes mehr machen
ist er gerade bei automatisch erzeugten Untertiteln ist diese Gefahr sehr deutlich schon jetzt
und ich würde noch hinzufügen ich sehe tatsächlich eine Chance und also.
Deshalb glaube ich sind wir hier mit dem Thema halt auch irgendwie anders sehr sehr schönen Stelle im im Chaos Umfeld und und in der in denen in den Communities die damit zu tun haben weil es irgendwie auch.
Dann doch im zwischenmenschlichen Ebene geht und irgendwie um also wenn wir Lösungen wollen dann kommen wir nicht drum rum dass wir miteinander ins Gespräch kommen
sollten dass wir irgendwie erstmal freundlich aufeinander zugehen und nicht irgendwelche Worte übelnehmen und verbieten sollen sagen so hängen erstmal erstmal reden können und dann können wir uns darüber unterhalten.
Wie wir miteinander reden wollen vielleicht und um daneben zu schauen okay also diese diese Community.
Ist ja unglaublich finde ich und da kommen super super viele Sachen raus ich glaube an der ein oder anderen Stelle.
Ja muss man muss man sich da irgendwie noch mal ein bisschen so vielleicht in den Fokus vielleicht noch mal irgendwie schärfen oder so und da auch deutlich machen dass das ist jetzt hier nicht so just for fun so es geht halt irgendwie
unbelebte ich will ja ich würde fast sagen gelebte radikale Demokratie wenn es um Zugänge geht.
Egal ob offline in der Hosen Welt oder
Digitale ich möchte ich weiß zwei Fragen stellen die sagen du will bisschen persönlich gefällt das Interesse sind aber die gerade wo du sagst dass mehr als wir reden hier jetzt also sehr offener sehr institutionellen und gesellschaftlichen Ebenen Jochens kleine gibt und das eine ist.
Tatsächlich sei einfach dieser Podcast na der auch schon ein bisschen größere Fragen wird das Chaos Radio ist er eine Sendung die sozusagen ein Anspruch hat die Welt ein kleines bisschen besser dadurch zu machen dass man Dinge erklärt,
ist die barrierefrei auf gar keinen Fall was will mich nicht haben ist ein Transkript dieser Sendung das liegt aber daran.
So und der frage ich jetzt unter dem Fest da ist gleich die Frage verbunden das können wir nicht leisten sind ein Trupp von Menschen.
Die sozusagen das alle aus Spaß an der Freude machen oder weil wir das Gefühl haben das ist etwas was die Welt braucht und wir investieren alle so viel wie wir können und seinen Transkript zu leisten schaffen wir nicht
aber natürlich ist es auch ein total valida. Zu sagen ihr wollt halt nicht und das stimmt die Menschen die das Chaos Radio machen brauchen das alle nicht
jetzt ist aber die Frage und sowas ist das eine wenn man könnte also sagen na ja aber das denn Barrierefreiheit als das Ideal dass wir unbedingt erreichen wollen dann muss das eine Anforderung sein.
Dann anderer Spruch der mir aber in dem Zug sagen bei dieser Problematik durch den Kopf geht ist eine befreundete zu Drogen hat man gesagt und ich weiß kann ich! Wo das herkommt anyways individueller verzichtet keine Lösung für gesellschaftliche Probleme.
Was heißt.
Die Frage ist wenn man jetzt im nördernfeld ist dann ist er dieser dieser Übergang halt fließen zwischen das ist mein Projekt wo jemand oder einen paar Leute Spaß an der Sache haben dann aber genau nur so viel machen wie sie Bock haben oder nicht.
Muss man bei Jere frei sein und.
Letztlich dann sagen okay wenn du das nicht leisten könnt dann sollt ihr bitte aber auch nicht den Podcast machen als jetzt ganz überzogen formuliert oder ist es auch okay das.
Nicht zu schaffen und ist das sozusagen valides Argument solange es eben nicht nimmt nicht nein sagen was ist wo man sich hinter versteckt.
Ich glaube schon dass es ein valides Argument ist es muss doch ein sein.
Was für ein Fach auch wichtig ist sowas wie gesunder Menschenverstand.
Wir reden ja an vielen Stellen einfach über gesetzliche Regelung letztlich gesetzliche Regelung weil es sonst keiner tut,
Frauenquoten oder so anfangen.
Es braucht die einfach anfangen
und das aus meiner Sicht das ist meine persönliche Meinung
ganz anders aus und was ich auch dabei noch wichtig finde ist das klang schon farmhud an ist halt dieser menschliche fuck
weißt du auch wenn man Mensch mit Einschränkungen ist man braucht ganz oft nicht die perfekte Lösung oder technisch oder nicht technisch sondern ein sichtbares bemühen.
Was dabei rauskommt und aber auch dieses dieses Leben es ist selbstverständlich dass man dabei ist auch wenn das gewisse Einschränkungen für beide Seiten.
Auch erstmal okay ist schon sehr schön ja und
ja ich bin auch ich persönlich bedauere manchmal dass es eine Menge broadcast gibt die sich die für mich einfach verschlossen bleiben aber auf der anderen Seite es gibt so viel input schriftlich.
Ich schaffe es eh nicht.
Niklas wolltest du auch noch ja gerne also.
Ich glaube es ich find's zum einen total cool wir haben in der Vorbereitung auch gemerkt dass das ist ganz schön anspruchsvoll hier uns alle miteinander zu.
Digital zu verknüpfen.
Ich komme aus meiner Kinder und Jugend Arbeitsecke Wurst immer also früher auch schon learning-by-doing ließ ich find das manchmal auch echt ganz schön frustrierend.
Ich glaube wenn es um das Chaos weitergeht oder andersrum.
Ich habe ja den Kontakt zum Chaosradio letztes Jahr gesucht weil ich eigentlich mal ein bisschen Staub aufwirbeln wollte in dem Chaos Umfeld.
Dann ist die Schwadron ihr da irgendwie immer schon seit einer Weile rum und glaube also und hatte so den Eindruck ich glaube ich find's cool wenn die Leute die sich damit assoziieren einfach.
Und wenn die sich 5 minuten wenn man dich 5 Minuten hinter sind überlegst mir und ja wie läuft das eigentlich so bei uns in unserer Gruppe oder.
Auf auf einem offenen möglichen nächsten offline stattfindenden Kongress.
Brandy so na also einfach die sich einfach nur mal die Frage zu stellen und ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger erster Schritt und ich glaube es geht darum Schritte zu machen und auf dem Weg zu sein also.
Ich finde es total geil was das Chaos Radio Team ja irgendwie auf die Beine stellt und dass wir diese Folge machen und wenn am Ende dabei übrig bleibt das irgendwie überlegt Soha.
Habe ich vielleicht irgendwie noch Zeit.
Die Woche irgendwie noch eine Transkription anzufangen oder nicht und selbst wenn nicht und wenn du irgendwer zehn Minuten Zeit hast und sag so aber ich gucke mal ob ich ihn finde.
Der vielleicht Bock an der Transkription 20 jetzt nur ein Beispiel zu bleiben oder heyho an die Leute da draußen hat den Spritzbeutel transmission
Ruhm und Ehre also so kann es halt laufen ich glaube es geht darum irgendwie auf dem Weg zu sein und ganz wichtig.
Nicht irgendwie mit Song auf song ja ich weiß nicht irgendwie auf so ein auf so einen unangenehmen schuld.
Trip da gilt Trip irgendwie Zusatzgewinn ich einfach alles sein lassen wenn wir hier nicht irgendwie das hinkriegen nee
wir sind alle auf dem Weg benutzen benutzen die Tools die uns gerade zur Verfügung gestellt werden um damit bessere zu bauen.
Danke habe ich jemand Lust da draußen mal voll die geile Transkription für diese Radiosendung zu machen die andere Frage die
mit einer kurzen Zusammenfassung also einmal sind alle auf dem Weg
die andere sagen kleine wirklich sehr ins Detail gehen die Frage ist die klar von schon mal ganz kurz an Screenreader und gender gap.
Das fand ich den total interessante Diskussion als die damals auf Karneval ist wo der darüber gesprochen also.
Hörerinnen wie stellt man das textlich da macht man das mit diesem Doppel e macht man das mit dem Sternchen macht man das mit dem Unterstrich und da war
eine Argumentation von Fiona macht das doch so und so Niklas hat das glaube ich vorhin schon angetippt kurz weil die Screenreader lesen das sonst falsch und.
Da hatte ich auch da war ich auch so einerseits andererseits einerseits kann ich das total gut verstehen.
Dass man sagt hey hier ist eine Gruppe von Menschen die Sprache einer bestimmten Art und Weise benutzt,
vielleicht könnte ich auch nach denen richten anders als Nachtisch so Screenreader das ist doch jetzt wirklich Technologie.
Und die Technologie muss ich doch der Sprache anpassen und nicht umgekehrt
aber wie bei all diesen Dingen kann ich das natürlich aus meiner Hochseil privilegierten Position natürlich total toll rum denken und habe keine Ahnung von nichts deswegen
würde ich bei Niklas auch anfangen aber auch von irgendwas gerne wissen wollen wie seht ihr das denn.
Also am konkreten Beispiel aber tatsächlich auch das ist ja auch die weiterführende Frage
muss ich müssen sich zukünftige Entwicklung an den derzeitigen technischen Stand von assistiven System anpassen oder sind die auch in der Verpflichtung Schritt zu halten.
Ja also ich finde es total dankbar dass du da noch mal den Punkt auf gereist weil das
zum Thema ist was mich einfach wieder extrem extrem beschäftigt und wütend macht also ich bin da auch bei deiner Vermutung und finde.
Das kann in Screen wieder leisten also ich komme aber auch aus einer über über studieren und Ausbildung irgendwie.
Sein Gewissen Denkrichtung und denkt und und sage ok Sprache wird unser Zugang zur Welt formt. Unser Denken und unsere Wahrnehmung und wenn wir.
Und jetzt gerade weiß ich nicht einig sind dass z.b. der gender Stern irgendwie das Mittel der Wahl ist um.
Das was wir wahrnehmen wollen wir uns zugänglich zu machen dann soll doch bitte die Assistenz Technologie sich da mal nicht so haben damit sind sie aber schnell in dem ganz anderen also wieder in dem anderen Bereich weil die Frage ist ja.
Wer steckt denn eigentlich hinter meiner Assistenz Technologie haben die Leute dann Interesse dran bis das irgendwie wir's schon paar mal hatten soll
obendrauf sonst plus was noch mal hinten so dran geschoben wird ja okay das machen wir jetzt auch noch
oder steckt da irgendwie auch ein gewisses anderes Interesse hinter hinter den da irgendwie Geld generieren oder oder irgendwie weiß ich nicht was.
Also ich glaube wenn ich so grob überschlage wenn es jetzt um Screen wieder wirklich geht.
Und und um akustische Ausgabe würde ich komme ich so auf 67 verschiedene Softwareprodukte also jetzt sowohl Desktop als auch irgendwie mobile Geräte und da steckt immer eine Firma hinter und.
Ja wir hatten in der Vorbereitung auf diese Frage wie funktioniert eigentlich inscription wieder das schöne daran ist ohne weiteres Detail gehen zu wollen die funktionieren gar nicht alle gleich.
Also in der Frage wie holen die sich Ihre Daten aus dem was dann was ich für Nut User-Agent beschrieben habe aus dem Browser oder aus meinem Mediaplayer oder aus meinem Texteditor whatever.
Das machen die nicht alle auf die gleiche Art und Weise da kocht jeder irgendwie jede Firma irgendwie so ein bisschen ihr eigenes Süppchen und.
Wir sind also ich kenn einer es gibt ein VDA läuft auf auf Microsoft Windows System das ist ein Open-Source-Projekt und es gibt ein Screen wieder in der Linux-Welt den ich kenne.
Möglicherweise kommt jetzt in Ordnung 2. und der Rest ist proprietär.
Also heißt das sozusagen also ich hatte ja ich hatte ja schon sagen ab und zu gefragt haben wir das selbe Problem wie in anderen
Facetten der Digitalisierung auch heißt dass auch hier die Aussage mein Screenreader kann das nicht ist eigentlich nur
Tja das Potemkin Schondorf für wir haben ja einen weiteren Bereich der Digitalisierung der voller proprietärer Geräte ist wohl nicht der Nutzer oder den NutzerInnen entscheidet was man den Geräten machen kann sondern die Hersteller die Geräte so zu macht dass man sie nicht ändern kann.
Ja ich glaube das ist der wo ich einfach mal so ein solides Jahr dranhängen Irmhild anscheinend nicht.
Weil wir haben wir sehen uns auch ein Bild und die wird ganz bedächtig und skeptisch mit dem Kopf gewackelt wenn ich das richtig interpretiere.
Ja also ich würde das
bisschen differenzierter sehen oder vielleicht einen zusätzlichen Aspekt bei Steuerbescheid wollen also grundsätzlich bin ich auch der Meinung die Technik das und sie muss es auch grillen und es ist auch ein Problem proprietärer Ltd.
Aber nicht nur also die Sache ist tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter weil AG Niklas eben schon sagte
die Art und Weise wie jetzt wenn der am weitesten wieder bleiben das was davor gelesen werden soll in den Screen wieder reinkommen falls Unterschied.
Und das bedeutet aber auch es ist wieder teilweise abhängig davon ist wie dieser Inhalt der da in den Screen wieder rein soll
markiertes
also ich schreibe z.b. gerade einen Text der in einer also digital den einer barrierefreien eBook erscheinen soll und ich bin angehalten jeden englischen Begriff den ich verwende auch als Englisch aus
Screenreader den korrekt vorlesen wieder im menschlichen Leben unterscheiden.
Deutsch spreche ich Deutsch aus und das ist jetzt Englisch und das muss ich Englisch aussprechen das muss ich ja gesagt werden.
Das ist so der 1. Der zweite Punkt bin ich aber vor allen Dingen beitragen will ist das ganze hängt
auch noch damit zusammen wie die verschiedenen BenutzerInnen und Benutzer ihre Screen wieder einstellen.
Weil viele deepreen wieder benutzen haben sie schon lange gewöhnt sind stellen ja z.b. die Geschwindigkeit sehr hoch das heißt die lassen sich viel viel schneller als.
Als lebende oder auch nicht hören die Menschen die Sachen vorlesen das ist doch wie so eine Art überfliegen beim Lesen und sie stellen ganz oft
mache ganz oft die Einstellung was eben Satzzeichen Sonderzeichen und ähnliches angeht also es ist ja die Frage ob ich einen Hut
einfach so wie er mich entsprechend würde vorlese oder ob ich sage ja, hier geht der Satz jetzt weiter.
Und so weiter ja.
Komm wir wieder in so ein Bereich wo man sagen muss naja muss man halt ein bisschen differenzierter sehen
das wollte ich noch ergänzen bitte nicht Ergebnis sondern nur ergänzen also auch dass Technologie die
beherrscht ein will auch dass er wieder sagen der Frage wer Zugänglichkeit Mehrwert wer kann eigentlich wie seine eigenen Geräte einstellen und die habe auch beherrschbar sein muss
aber die man auch und dann wiederum auch ein Standardproblem das ist ja tatsächlich sagen aber was was mich schon häufig begegnet ist das sage ich immer gesagt wir hätten gerne den einen Weg
wie Daten präsentiert werden nämlich so dass sie möglichst sozusagen einfach verarbeitet werden können und das nachvollziehbar ist was da passiert
wir haben jetzt ganz viele Teilbereiche.
Gestriffen ich würde ein heute gerne auslassen die rechtliche Seite weil da hatten wir eigentlich Sport und Verein geladen ist dann ganz kurzfristig behindert gewesen ich würde nur.
Das in dem Sinne aufgreifen, dass ihr ja gesagt hat es gibt zumindest im geschäftlichen Bereich und vor allen Dingen was offizielle Stellen angeht
gewisse Vorschriften dass bei ihrer Freiheit gewährleistet sein muss und ich will es gar nicht in die Tiefe gehen also ich fragen was für Gesetze gibt es wie wer steckt Geld dort so weiter und so fort sondern einfach zum Schluss der Sendung noch mal so drei Sachen in Richtung praktische Lebenshilfe
zum Einstieg in ein barrierefreies Leben bieten und das erste ihm auf diesem Bereich abziehen wenn ich jetzt jemand bin der davon betroffen ist das dein Angebot.
Das eigentlich so sein mir Zugang verschaffen möchte das nicht tut weil eben diese Barrierefreiheit oder diese Zugängigkeit fehlt was kann ich da tun.
Wie ist da die Situation am Tag haben wir wieder im Vergleich zum Datenschutz ihn da gibt's die datenschutzgrundverordnung in der Theorie werden empfindliche Bußgelder verhängen praktisch ist das dann immer so eine Frage wie ist das denn hier in dem Bereich kann ich was machen wenn ich betroffen bin
Und und sage so hier das geht so eigentlich nicht ihr müsst mir eigentlich Zugang gewähren gibt es da Mittel und Wege.
Zumindestens inter Sachen der EU-Richtlinie die ja für öffentliche Stellen gilt gibt es diesen Feedback Mechanismus aber da gibt's noch Überwachungsstellen aber die hängen wieder Bußgelder.
Die versuchen das halt durchzusetzen irgendwie aber.
Ist halt schwierig einer Behörde ein Bußgeld anzudrohen weil wer schreibt es eines Bußgeld richtig eine andere Behörde da dabei sie hat dann
bitte die Schlange ihr Schwanz ist wird dann im öffentlichen Sektor mit Snoopy nexible attack noch mal bisschen was anderes wenn Abflug dann Leute auch sagen können ey du musst mir das Zugänglichmachen ist gleiche Zahl mir auch ein.
Das ist unterschiedlich aber es gibt diesen Feedback Mechanismus und die Behörden müssen darauf reagieren
und ich sollte Schlimmste was glaube ich dir vor es geht es nur Verbandsklagen prinzipiell aber das natürlich so die die höchste mögliche Eskalationsstufe und die sind auch immer schwierig dann auch wenn du auf die zu machen.
Das hört sich alles gibt theoretisch Werkzeuge praktisch ist es aber schwierig.
Ja es gibt dazwischen auch noch die sogenannten Schiedsverfahren also.
Das da das habe ich auch schon mal gemacht gemacht weil die Behörde an die ich mich gewendet hatte nämlich schlicht mich reagiert hat was ich natürlich nicht so gut fand verständlicherweise
und deswegen habe ich mich dann sozusagen an die zuständige Stelle an die zuständige Überwachung
und die ist dann auch tätig geworden was nur bedeutet dass sie einen Brief schreibt und der Behörde dann sagt dudududu genug und daraufhin wiederum hat die Behörde einen Brief geschrieben und gesagt ja aber die Sache ist ja ganz kompliziert und wir sind ja eigentlich nicht zuständig und deswegen gilt dir ich sehen wir ja wenn wir das eng auslegen hier
man beachte
wann alles Juristen wieder miteinander kommuniziert wir sind ja ganz großzügig und in der nächsten Version verbessern
das ist dann tatsächlich auch passiert man höre und staune.
Aber ja also das ist tatsächlich noch ein Problem ist aber auch irgendwie blöd weil das
wem ist halt das Problem was wir eben hatten die Leute die Karte bei öffentlichen Stellen die die Webseiten bei ihre frei machen müssen müssen das nachträglich tun es ist eben nicht von vornherein mitgedacht
dann haben sie schon gemacht haben
dafür gibt es auch oft Gründe und wann kommen Sie irgendwelche Leute und sagen ihr habt aber nicht ihr habt aber nicht ihr habt aber nicht und dann geht das dann rechtlichen Weg der hilft eigentlich kein
wirklich außer eben wenn es gut läuft du bist fein zu schaffen
und da wäre es eigentlich schön wenn es da andere Wege geht.
Klingt für mich so ein bisschen so als ob das ein einen eine ehrenwerte aktivistische Arbeit ist solche Verfehlung sozusagen anzufechten oder aufzuzeigen aber.
Im praktischen Leben nicht konkret und schnellhilfe angezeigt ist durch sowas.
Gib mir die umgedrehte Seite an.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Projekt mache die Frage dann auch so bisschen an Dennis der sagen als Dienstleister auch fungiert für Leute die sagen ich habe hier ein digitales Angebot das soll jetzt auch bei ihre frei sein was sind denn gute Dinge die man
Bernd ja schon besprochen dass man am besten gleich am Anfang an dran denkt die man mitbringt wenn man.
Den Bordstein um das Bild vom Anfang zu benutzen nicht so hoch machen will.
Na das fängt einfach das nicht an sich einfach zu beschäftigen was das möchte man erreichen Sie möchten uns erreicht also Designprozess schon anzufangen und ist echt wirklich einfache Tools die mit die Kontrastwerte einchecken
da muss man gar nicht mehr wissen welcher genaue Wert das ist das Ding sagt einem nur grün oder rot oder ja oder ok das sind auch selber nicht bei ihre frei diese Tools.
Aber das ist so der erste Weg mal Anfang hatten sich finde diese WCAG ist ultra hilfreich ist denkt weil natürlich sehr sehr viel
normativ geregelt also eine Webseite muss das und das Können und der Nutzer Nutzerin kann jederzeit eine Schriftgröße ändern und darf nichts kaputt gehen
aber was immer da drunter ist sind immer so so könntest du das erreichen
Vorschläge bist du wirklich so Sachen denkt halt so so als er abstrakte Sachen wie die Nutzerin muss immer wissen wo sie sich auf der Webseite gerade befindet
wie reicht man denn das jetzt ehrlich gesagt und da steht da drunter so so ein Hinweis ja du könntest eine Sitemap anbieten oder so eine Brut brotkrumennavigation breadcrumb-navigation oder das oder dass oder das so kannst du es erreichen das ist ultra praktisch.
Was halt sehr von der praktische Umsetzung gelegen ist das lohnt sich sehr aber da reinzulesen zu gucken was das Können der Weg sein das zu erfüllen diese Voraussetzung finde ich zum Essen.
Ich glaube also kann das Dennis total zustimmen und soweit ich in die Vici RG reingeguckt hat finde ich ist es ein super Ressource
was wir mit be able e.v. machen ist ja auch so ein bisschen uns da einzumischen also weniger jetzt wie bei der vorherigen Frage ob seine rechtlichen Ebene sondern wir versuchen da im auch ein Angebot zu machen.
Um mit.
Auch im Zweifelsfall Unternehmen zusammen Designprozesse mit Inklusion zusammenzubringen und von vorne rein.
Dass das irgendwie zu denken so leid da geht's manchmal nicht nur um digitale Produkte da geht's manchmal auch um so wichtig noch zu Dinge die man so anfassen kann die so aus.
Elementen bestehen aber.
Ich glaube oder was du meine Motivation auch immer so herkamen war Verständnis bei den Leuten irgendwie hervorrufen und ich glaube das geht nur.
Über das Kennenlernen der Lebensumstände also ich würde fast du Gewalt gehen und sagen nur was ich selbst erlebt habe kann ich.
Wirklich richtig nachfüllen nachvollziehen so aufs offene Ebene die über so ein.
Hat's rein rational ja okay das ist logisch hinausgeht und ich glaube wenn der Punkt erreicht ist also.
Wie viele Leute mir irgendwie nach irgendwelchen Aktionen dann noch Mails geschrieben haben und gesagt haben eh bei jeder Ampel fällt mir jetzt plötzlich auf die die klickt und piept und ich kann dann Knopf drücken.
Das habe ich vorher nie gemerkt oder hier sind ja überall hier so Riffel Pflaster also und jetzt so ganz klassische bei ihrer Abbau Sachen in der in der begehbaren Welt.
Anzüge anzubringen also das hat mir mal wieder gezeigt.
Das macht total viel Sinn sich damit auseinanderzusetzen und ich glaube da gibt's gute Vereine an die man sich wenden kann.
Und wenn man halt Bock drauf hat Pipetten.
Na ja man kann ja auch ruhig noch größer denken also wenn schon denn schon würde ich vorschlagen das ganze würde ja auch viel viel einfacher werden wenn Menschen mit
welchen Einschränkungen auch immer viel selbstverständlicher auch überall wären.
Sei es in der Schule weil ich im Arbeitsleben
neues im Alltag im Verein oder sonstwo weil dann nämlich auch wieder jemanden kennt und wie Niklas auch dachte zumindest eine Idee hat.
Was eigentlich bedeutet wenn jemand nicht sehen nicht hören mich rauchen kann weiß der Geier und dann auch daran
das ist doch das Entscheidende das mal überhaupt das haben wir ja schon ausgearbeitet auf die Idee kommt ja mal darüber nachzudenken dass es eben nicht alles nicht alles so funktionieren wie ich gerade selber Gehrig.
Oder Alpen
da oder weiß der Geier was da und jetzt gerade meinetwegen auch nur den Akkuschrauber nur für Männer Hände sein.
Das ist doch.
Anfangen darüber nachzudenken ich glaube das ist so sagen der Punkt wo ich das hätte ich die sendung gerne beenden würde
weil ich hoffe das haben wir erreicht wenn ihr zu sagen nicht Dennis Irmhild oder Niklas sagen nein wir haben diesen einen wichtigen Punkt noch vergessen den müssen wir noch besprechen möchte ich euch.
An dieser Stelle eine kurze Pause geben um diese Gelegenheit verkaufen.
Und ansonsten sagen lieber Dennis liebe Irmhild lieber Niklas vielen Dank dass ihr heute zu Gast wart dass wir alle so geduldig zusammen durchgestanden haben dass wir technisch auch zusammenkommen konnten und für die schönen Einblicke dir uns gegeben habt und auch
geben
das möglich machen das mal Anfang drüber nachzudenken weil ich kann jetzt sagen wieder nur anekdotisch von mir selbst erzählen diese
diese Idee die Freude sozusagen also die Fröhlichkeit möchte ich fast sagen mit dir in das Thema mitnimmt
und auch so ein bisschen das beruhigende das ist es mir so ein bisschen peinlich nur weil ich sozusagen der bin der am wenigsten irgendwie davon betroffen ist und jetzt trotzdem immer so Angst davor habe das Thema anzufassen aber diese Fröhlichkeit zu sagen hey es ist es ist schon total gut wenn wir überhaupt versuchen und wir streben die Perfektion an und ist aber auch klar dass die nicht im ersten Schritt erreicht sein muss
das finde ich auch in Gedanken den ich mir einfach meinte die Ohren schreiben sollte um das sozusagen um da keine Berührungsängste mehr sagen also diesen Sinne vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank auch an scars Radio Team ist diese Sendung organisiert zusammengestellt und redaktionell geplant hat vielen Dank auch an die Gebärdendolmetscherin die möglich gemacht haben dass wir so flüssig und.
Zusammen sprechen konnten vielen Dank an Euch liebe hören dass ihr wieder dabei wart das war das Chaos Radio 275 und mir bleibt nur noch
eine Sache zu sagen lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups tschüss.
Music.